if
you guys
weren't in my life
my life would be much worse
and i'm not
i don't know if i would be alive and
that's the truth
oh there it is
you guys were there for me during my
darkest [ __ ] and i love you all i love
the three of you man i love you there it
is
what a [ __ ] huh
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
i was on stage
yeah and i was talking he was on the
ship he popped in and they were like he
wants to go up and i was like he's going
to do [ __ ] 40 minutes because then
i'm going to leave and they were like
nah he's going to do shorts i was like
i'll hang around he got up at like 15
minutes so i'm like okay that's cool man
if you want to come in you want to do a
little spot test it out for 15 minutes
okay and how was this set
he actually got laughs for the ice i saw
him uh struggle like three times and
then this time i saw him do
uh you know he got some laughs i mean it
wasn't
by any means but it was cool the crowd
got to see ti and you know i don't know
um i feel stronger in this seat but uh
but then i went on and uh and i was
talking about how it's hilarious it's
like the only job you can just
short
skip to
to the top i know yeah i mean
it's the joke i was making about you
but about how like no but the same thing
but it's also it's like it's like dude
okay you could do stand-up
no but ti you can do stand-up no you
can't but you can do stand-up but then
you have to live in a house that i build
because i don't do that yeah so you know
what i mean yeah but it's like this is
not my job i will build you a house yeah
but to that point it's like yeah he can
jump to the toppings of the comedy store
and laughter factory
but that's
he's not gonna be able to build a career
no i know that because after a while
people go yeah that's ti dude yeah
no but you don't have it but he'll get
the problem though is that he's still
gonna get allowed the chance to be like
how many comedy clubs if he said i'm
gonna do a ti tour
it's gonna happen oh yeah what's gonna
happen but i'm fine with that in the
black market too he's gonna be out there
he's gonna be at atlanta comedy he's
gonna sell it out but look it depends
yeah even if he starts if he's bombing
he'll have one run you have one run
you'll get the one run or two
more than that's if he's headlined more
than two years all right then we got
something but here's the thing though
but no here's the thing but if you're
gonna promote yourself on the show fine
that's fine that's cool brings people to
the like if you're gonna sell tickets
and there's gonna be an audience you
can't complain about that that's good
then
we go on the shows great we perform
[ __ ] people that want to see tia who
gives a [ __ ] yeah but but um if you're
not gonna promote it and then you're
gonna bump people do 40 minutes then
then that's the thing where it's like
all right you know well that's where the
comedy places have put their foot down
yeah dude i'm going to find who you are
yeah you ain't coming out here bumping
off these legit communities who have
been here for years man just because you
had that hot track seven years ago yeah
yeah you look at charlie remember
charlie sheems trying to do the the
tiger blood tour yeah two shows and
people like dude it's awful and then he
had to bring jeff ross on and all these
other dudes yeah like get uh it wasn't
even mike tyson doing comedy or trying
uh i think he had like a one-man show he
had one match who actually saw it was
like it wasn't even coming it was like a
one-man play yeah okay that was
critically acclaimed yeah yeah people
did end up like
great
brennan cried at it um yeah speaking of
tours phoenix i just added another show
oh wow
chrisalia.com you gotta do this at the
beginning of the show i'm gonna tell you
then i'm gonna be coming back let me
kind of do my thing though okay phoenix
go to crystallia.com
we are opening up another show
chrisleya.com phoenix another show at
the celebrity theater so front row
ticket go get those front row tickets
right now and when are you there april
30th april 14th before you see chris
april 14 15 16. i'm in phoenix stand up
live in arizona then april 22nd through
23rd i'm at cap city moon tower coming
festival sickboy.com special drops of
28th on thick boy as well
holla y'all have no uh what's it called
there decorum yeah
that's how do i have decorative
man i'll be in albuquerque on may 18th
uh dude that's a read from a phone
midland
memorize your date midland texas no
respect which is a real place
it's a place may 19 at midland lubbock
texas may 20
dallas at the 21st
and then uh i got some dates in june uh
coming up that's gonna be savannah and
uh uh
some other joints uh
dress like you have white water rafting
toys
[Music]
this is eddie bauer though yeah thank
you if you if you wore that at
whitewater rafting you're the first guy
that drowned yeah i mean that's too
light you gotta
no you could say you would drown
and why is that theo huh why is that an
ink
i think he's saying he would he would
hold you under no yeah he thinks half of
you would drive
i was on the yeah team yeah i used to
swim but then i had to stop because they
said you should shave and it's just not
going to happen really yeah stand for
something yeah they said [ __ ] just like
a bear just going through there
looking for salmon
sorry yeah i was at the beverly hills
ymca back in the day
swimming under him
sucking off of him feeding off from the
sucker gonna be back guys
yeah always have to end it with that and
that's so annoying to me but you do it
and it's my thing it's funny yes you can
hear what annoys me
no i can sing like um let's hear it
don't talk about it he sounds like an
asian when he's saying to you isn't that
weird no he's just saying no he sounds
like an asian person
oh you mean like one of those people
that karaoke they can't speak english
but all of a sudden they're like this is
my impression
hahaha
[Music]
so exaggerated
but it's like a sumo wrestler he's like
sugar
just here come on now i gotta hear it
theo hit it wish i had it for you guys
it's okay
big time now
i'm playing midland now dude i know
i do a lot of black some black women
come out yeah funeral i'll sing at all
karaoke i do a lot of chris uh christmas
carol that's right that's a bummer
singing silent night in fact that's
[ __ ] uh in the in the funeral just
hey who put them peeps up there my mouth
is watering daddy i have some that
haven't touched the uh table i think no
i got cavities i don't need peeps i've
never eaten a pizza you've never had a
peep no
end of discussion
what else would you like to talk about
but you have you've had a chocolate
rabbit
dude yeah yeah of course you eat ear or
ass first yeah i go ass no i go
i go ask first eric i'm not even gonna
[ __ ] you like he's over here
he's like we know who goes ass first
eric you want to talk about how you like
to eat ass you gotta go first
you eat the bottom of it yeah you gotta
go you know
i don't like eating them chocolate
rabbits because it's too hard to manage
really i like a smaller snack i like the
um bring up the couldn't agree with you
more easter egg bring up the cadbury
nestle egg nestle egg yeah nestle
i couldn't agree with you more dude it's
it's too much it melts chocolate melts
and [ __ ] in your hand bro that's why you
need the hollow ones
i mean i get it
you can look over there
on that screen theo feels like a i can
see right here
preacher and like a
angry southern preacher yeah those are
good those are good those are good thank
you yeah those are good yeah you're
welcome
daddy can't touch any of those i got
four cavities do you you do get them
filled dude no i'm not losing weight
i don't fix my teeth so i don't need
sugar oh
that's a reverse psychology is that
called reverse psychology yeah maybe i
know i think it's called don't know
smart i think it's called he's gross
dude he has four cavities do you have
cavities i've never had a cabbage
i've never had cabbage really yeah
[ __ ] never had a cavity you've had
cavities but i don't have any right now
yeah you've never had one i've never had
one no i mean i no i've never had a
cavity dude i brushed my teeth yeah you
said one i'll do two but also tons of
sugar tons of sugar but it is a cavity
though he's like black and white
and we're back let's go
let's go to this blue eye this blue-eyed
angel right here
his hair came with the hat it's not even
boys it's dalton from wisconsin
had a little name game for you guys
where's maybe related items but it never
gets his name peter cottontail
cincy let's hear it boys and since he
didn't get off the rails a little bit
you know with the autism and all
love to hear chin be the judge of this
keep you fellas in line
so yeah
name game
doing stand-up comedy soon
look up to you guys so thanks for the
content it means the world to me
hopefully i can open for you guys one
day oh name game
game game buzz buzz or song
wow what's up guys gonna take a little
break from the king and the sting in the
wing this week because i'm here to tell
you it's time it's happening my special
drops on thick boy youtube april 28th
it's coming in hot the gringo poppy 30
minutes of pure fire lighten up my
mexican family tune in april 28th on
thick boy youtube the gringo poppy your
boys 30 minute special please tune in i
beg you let's take a little break from
king the sting and the wind
because gentlemen did you know two out
of three men will experience some form
of hair loss by the time that they're 35
more than 50 million bros in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness i see
at my shows man i see it at my shows
you're going bald man i'll be seeing a
lot of those bald heads this weekend in
phoenix thursday friday saturday but
listen my friends at keeps offers a
simple affordable stress-free way to
keep your freaking hair you meet with a
doctor virtually all right they have 24
7 care and support you any questions we
got you man a real person talks to you
it's low cost treatments start just ten
dollars per month keeps offers generic
versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss
treatment plans are affordable typically
half the cost of pharmacy prices so go
to my friends at keeps keeps us
everything you need to keep your hair
it's delivered straight to your door
discreet little package all right proven
results remember prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
see results so act fast if you're ready
to take action prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com cats that's
keps.com cats to get your first month of
treatment for free that's keeps.com cats
to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-e-s dot com slash cats
all right buckaroos the nba playoffs
mean next level basketball it's getting
real get ready for all the action by
betting the play in tournament with
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the nba new customers
can bet five dollars on any team to win
and get 150 dollars in free bets
instantly you clinch a win no matter
what all draftkings sportsbook customers
can also bet on nba hoops with the same
game parlays your boy's a betting man
here i like parlays you feel me nick
combine multiple bets from the same game
for a bigger payout the more legs you
add the more money you can win plus for
each day of the playing get a risk free
bet up to ten dollars if your same game
parlay doesn't hit download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code cats kats bet five dollars on
any nba team to win their game during
the playing tournament and get 150
dollar rules and free bets instantly
that's promo code cats at draftking
sportsbook an official sportsman partner
of the nba minimum age and eligibility
restriction supplies see show notes for
details see next page for directions for
disclaimers
what city is he what what uh he didn't
say i don't want to
i don't know if it's my fault but i
don't know what he was saying
name as many easter things as you can oh
they don't know the name
they don't know the name game they
haven't played the game oh no yeah i
haven't played it and that's a good
thing easter related items you just go
around the room and you say something
easter related sometimes it gets a
little dicey so chin will uh say whether
or not sometimes me and theo repeat the
same thing twice yeah yeah i do not but
mainly him you guys celebrate easter
though
we don't celebrate the religious side of
it we do the egg hunt and all that stuff
oh wow yeah whoa how weird
yeah you're just looking for [ __ ] so
you don't have to we don't feel like at
least we're doing it for jesus don't
care about the lord never celebrating my
family done neither i wouldn't chin on
this we should do that thing where they
would like i remember in somebody's
place in our neighborhood they would do
a thing where they would dig up a jesus
like the uh like a zombie jesus
everybody would get like a shovel and
you would dig up a jesus to like start
that was the fbi they found bodies
no it was a jesus small it was a
i guess it was a small get together
guys we're looking for jesus
because jesus returns on easter
no he doesn't you know what i mean
hey buddy oh you want to go to hell but
no he doesn't because
[Laughter]
shall i finish
i mean
it's up to you and satan yeah
bro we don't need it this little light
of mine
i'm going to let it shine
smack my bench up of course you would go
to white christmas of course
just like the one i use same note
wow
what is that for
i don't know e eric starts oh name game
easter
eggs okay put that down good there
me theo really hates the wheel does it
have to be easy i just it pretty i don't
like the engine
yeah it blocks our energy the [ __ ] why'd
you pick an e god damn it what is this
[ __ ] game so do i go yeah dude wait
you don't play games or congratulations
[ __ ] everything you do right yeah yeah
okay so
if it counts bunny
yes okay
super easy so far
yeah that might be the stripper cadbury
egg
sure cool but say all the syllables but
okay yeah cabaret
savior
yes all right dude we talked about but
you know dude
you know hades for you resurrection
the matrix so my turn yeah
okay oh it's getting hard
look at he's laughing because he doesn't
know what to do
immediately
he said egg rabbit
sandwich okay um
baskets yes
um
peeps
mexican auntie cow we were talking about
peeps earlier yeah
they can't only serve them at easter
yeah i would agree i don't want to give
it to you but i have to agree okay now
it's getting dicey ham
[Music]
easter ham google easter oh no i will
say this i do remember having dinner
yesterday yeah i would say yes yeah type
dinner dinner i would i would maybe give
it christmas
i don't think i'm not chinese i'm korean
i don't know the religious part about it
but i guarantee ham is part of easter
yeah
look at that bam boom
[Applause]
i'll tell you what if you don't get this
i lost
okay what am i going to do think of
another one i can't yeah
hiding stuff
that's true it doesn't need to be one
word it needs to be something i can't
say
don't attack him man hiding things he
already said eggs that's what you hide
no that's why he's heads hiding stuff
instead of hiding eggs this is good
okay eating stuff wow
like a ham
i'm gonna be a little okay i'm not gonna
be like north carolina i'm being more
stringent now after this one eating
stuff when you get to me
yeah after that [ __ ] we already lost
he said
[Music]
yeah i think that's good but that's also
eggs eggs no that's a certain oh no no
hold on that's a certain type of egg
yeah he said he said cadbury eggs and
now plastic eggs leather eggs
hard-boiled eggs and just say
hard-boiled eggs no that's not easter
yes it is classic eggs is hard boiled
you guys don't have any compassion and
we're one degree away i like this i
agree
i have no passion in my heart unreal
i'll handle this
um
pastel colors
yes because you paint eggs that's a good
one dude excellent that's a good one
[ __ ] i got one though thank you and god
bless everyone too i want to say that
yeah no no no god all right use that for
your next round um lent
no
sorry eric what
isn't this the start that was like when
denzel washington did one for training
day and didn't win for the other thing
yeah
you should have failed on the [ __ ]
other hiding stuff yes that was right i
like the hiding stuff that was the land
was a little almost a little too much
yeah i think i would give lent before
hiding so you know explain lent
isn't it like the whole like you give up
stuff yeah yeah yeah doesn't that start
right now that's not an easter egg no
it's not easter eggs oh yeah you give up
something so you're prepared for
christ's return yeah but that's like
that's a stretch you don't need to do
and why do stuff on with you
the further you get out there they don't
know what's going on this year london
takes place on wednesday march 2nd march
2nd
to thursday april 14th
easter takes place on april 16th so that
youtube
this is leading up to
bro so is [ __ ] new year's day it's
two days a week this is awesome believe
this
is a part of easter you sell no a lot
you wound yourself
lent is a part of easter well it just
said right there it's not part of easter
it's [ __ ] two days it ends and then
it's
i love you eric but you know eric loss
[ __ ] yeah dude hell yeah [ __ ] yeah i
knew i was gonna win you lost dude just
like people who don't believe in christ
yep
both he is about he's still in it he's
gonna lose next but he'll oh oh we go
until we all there's a winner that's it
oh yeah no the three of us won yeah the
three of us won
you lost there's one it's the only game
where there's one loser and that's the
real winner because you're the loser
so you're the loser you're the biggest
loser okay okay let's get to this
is this the nurse what's up theo brendan
and chris my name's jade and i'm
currently in los angeles california and
our quick little debate club for you
do you think acting is easy
got it um i currently am an actor here
in los angeles and i
get a good amount of auditions but i
currently book none of them which is
super fun for me and my bank account um
but i do get auditions where i'm
literally saying one line like i'm like
yeah yeah no problem the restroom's
right there on the left
or i get auditions where i'm memorizing
17 pages worth of shakespearean dialogue
and i know we can't all be on the acting
level the king speech acting level like
chris is but thank you
is acting hard is it easy
love your guys's podcast gang gang buzz
buzz soar i got it good luck let me tell
you why you got that role as the it's
over here
i don't think it has anything to do with
acting skills here's the deal you
don't
hollywood should not have people
audition for one line it's [ __ ]
ludicrous it's shitty it's a waste of
time people are battling three hours of
traffic to drive down a [ __ ] santa
monica and go up to the 19th floor and
just say what the [ __ ] she's saying hire
someone off a picture furthermore do
commercials [ __ ] just hire someone
off of the off of the picture dude it's
so [ __ ] annoying and it's okay and
it's a power move and they're doing it
because they're the big [ __ ]
and you will drive there of course
you're not going to band together and
not go because you got to [ __ ] eat
and you want to become that actress or
actor but
acting at a certain level is hard it's
hard to book a role and it's hard to
play like brian cranston in breaking bad
that role is [ __ ] a difficult role to
play but for the most part and i mean 99
percent of stuff
it's [ __ ]
as [ __ ]
i take full offense stop acting like
it's hard you aren't a brain surgeon
you're
only saying
easy [ __ ] dude that's it that's it it's
so simple it's so simple unless you're
doing king speech
or some [ __ ] like that and really
selling it or you're doing the [ __ ]
fighter like christian bale and you're
losing a bunch of weight and you're
acting all [ __ ] strung out it's easy
as [ __ ] dude don't give me [ __ ] like
captain america playing captain america
is easy it's easy bro long days
bro be a [ __ ] tannin bomber
chris isn't upset at all about no no i
love it it's just annoying no it's not
hollywood it's the actors dude you're
not yelling at us
yeah you
dude that you're upset about no it's not
about that you can't even act like you
believe in god like the rest of us yeah
i'll do it right now ready do it
[Laughter]
dude unreal they did an x-ray of him bro
it was just a dog getting hit by a van
dude there's nothing in him no i will
answer this it's so easy it's so easy to
act well yes absolutely
look i i completely disagree i think
that there are things that are like
whatever but i think uh some of the
things have to do with like the person's
charisma the person's like a lot of
things
are funny but that's not actually that's
true
not really yes it is if you're playing
yourself it has to be pretty [ __ ]
easy you play yourself a lot you play
yourself a lot that's not true if you're
daniel day lewis no i i do crazy [ __ ]
like that no no you never see me walk
around in my house i could kill it dude
if i if i if they put me playing
somebody with like they never would but
like and i'm just not even trying to
push the limits but if i wanted if they
wanted me to play somebody with down
syndrome
i get nominated they're not do it
they're not going to do that do peanut
butter number two do it
okay let's go look guys
he's going to hell we know he's going to
hell what are you saying
[Laughter]
sean penn played that [ __ ] role and
he killed it he played a guy with down
syndrome and i'm just saying with me if
i were to do it
where's all that chicken i had
with all that chicken i had what all
that chicken i had mom no that's your
friend mark
sounds like marquez that's some guy that
works at a popeye
that's all he doesn't he doesn't realize
he's on a shift
yeah we saw that chill that's some guy
who got it who works at a popeyes but
got some hot sauce in his eyes
[Laughter]
shut the [ __ ] up sometimes okay look
chin made that poster yeah look at this
look at the little writing on the chin's
is that kevin bacon
all right go ahead i would like to say
that this lady seems like a nice lady
and um
and acting i think it's hard and easy at
the same time it's like it's kind of
like
it's like uh
it's like being a snail kind of you know
[Music]
go on i don't know yet but yeah it looks
it looks real hard but it's easy
[Music]
i think and i think this lady seemed
like a nice lady and yes i would be
willing to go out with you sometimes
there it
probably there it is folks i'm taking my
chances you goons
yeah fewest you creeps already married
somebody yeah i'm close creeps though
you know because you're the creepiest
well in another year you guys will be
probably offering the same thing so
let me have my fun while i can dude i'm
a decent man she can obviously do a one
or two line just hire her you know what
i mean like that's the point it's like
she's just obviously handled she's a
skill the whole thing hollywood is just
it's a it's a trap it's trash and
they're going to make you drive all over
there they don't care some man sleeps in
his bed just you know probably following
people in gps or driving for auditions
ejaculation it's all zoom now and it's
all gross is it zooming yeah i do a lot
of zoom um
i think just make your own little sitcom
at home and then you'll be a star in
like a year you know yeah
yeah yes if she did that she would get
[ __ ] different yeah
i i just i i drove around for so i drove
around so many [ __ ] hours and hours
and then i finally made it dude hold on
and it just stopped and if tom's curry
and brendan had a baby right
yeah and it had a little more brendan in
it than tyler
that's boston a little bit of this
character that chris is doing
with all that chicken i put mom
that's this guy i don't think chris has
ever met anybody with down syndrome mom
where did you put all the chicken i was
storing
no bro this guy seemed like a great guy
[Music]
it's mike from chicago i got a debate
club for you of course it is you could
switch lives with anybody in the cast
chris theo brendan eric
if you could switch lives who would you
switch with and why
by cars clothes fashion career who would
you switch with and why
and also just to test these friendships
in these seats
if you could improve somebody's life by
switching with them
who would it be
oh well that's theo
who would it be this is heavy
shout out to them boys nick and chan and
the behind the glass boys doing all this
work man we love y'all and the whole
crew gang gang buzz buzz
what's all this [ __ ] about me being dead
inside bro
you open the [ __ ] up no i i i i'm i'm
open bro i cry almost every day every
day every day
hi just chris therapist i love my i love
my life dude i love it i wouldn't switch
with any all [ __ ] i love you
know what i like your lives too you guys
have great lives you really do but that
sounds like he's reading that off of a
screen yeah yeah yeah you know what yeah
you just went hollywood for a second
yeah here's the real the best thing
you've ever done
i'm doing great i'll probably switch
with chris because we we have the same
style so nothing really changes we can
keep the same ferraris a dope house
nothing would change man yeah that's
true but change a lot for you yeah but
then nothing would change man oh how
that's so deep dude nothing would be
really new or not
that's deep you know that's deep
that's deep over here you're a different
girl though when you get over here it
gets deeper dude you know you guys are
over there deep in kitty it's shallow
over here huh you guys are over here in
kiddie pool with your
dad right
and i'm over here in the [ __ ] d okay
so here's the thing at least they would
know their dad and remember him
how about that
these are daddy remembers this dude
i would say whose life would i switch
with um
this is a tough one man for the guy's
reasons too though oh for the
willingness to improve their lives yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think i would probably
switch
oh
i'd probably switch with each one of you
guys to have the opportunity to try and
improve y'all's life
dude you're you're too really less
better you're too religious no i'm not
what would you add to like each person
well brendan if i went to brennan's life
i would probably take it easier relax a
little bit more maybe
sit outside sometimes
maybe relax i already hate what you do
with my body let's go over here chris if
you're not gonna
try more stuff yeah i would probably
want to go somewhere i would jump rope
outside listen to music
no i don't want to do it don't be doing
that with my ears take chris's body into
a bunch of drugs i would jump rope i
would hug somebody yeah i hug people
dude nobody believes that but you would
yes i do but people don't believe that
dude i would i would um the hug would
feel weird you know i hug you bro and
what else whatever you do if i were him
probably can you tag me in real quick
because i go into your body you wanna
know what i do let him finish yeah go
ahead if i was eric i would probably
um
relax a little more he wants everybody
be outside maybe walk go for a walk
coming from the guy who doesn't well you
do go places to relax but you ski
yeah
no his brain doesn't relax
right right right his body he doesn't
work like a million shows i'll be
sitting there doing nothing dude but my
brain is doing a lot he's exhausted yeah
wow so and also eric if i were you i'd
probably try some different more novel
foods maybe a korean dish whatever yeah
[ __ ] some type of rare
whatever you guys eat
[Music]
what else do more black [ __ ]
i would do more black [ __ ]
i would darken out a little you think so
yeah i would if i were you if i got into
your body and i had that halfway that in
and out yeah i'm using the n-word all
the time oh
yeah
driving down the street just yelling out
the car well you do that anyway
yeah
but now he feels like he would have like
[Laughter]
yeah i think i would get out a little
bit more basically if i were all three
and relax relax was a really stuck thank
you i would jump in theo's body real
quick and realize what a badass i am i
don't want to get serious here about
jumping theo's body and realize what a
[ __ ] badass i am and quit beating
myself up and launched the biggest tour
of my life and know i'm gonna sell that
[ __ ] out yeah yeah i jump into theo be
like oh
i can do i could do more than just the
one podcast and i could do two podcasts
and be there all the time and it's not
gonna kill me that's what i would do if
i was you i'd be like you know what this
is okay i got people that support me i
got a great staff you know people love
me
you know what i mean and i'd be like
accept that and be like let's let's do
it you know what i mean
that's what that's what i would do i
would be like because you know what i
mean you're a great dude man
and i don't think you need to believe
this [ __ ]
yeah thank you bro
thank you guys i would uh be eric and
just do more stuff for crystalia
you'd wear his merch all the time [ __ ]
for my shows
but yeah it's not bad i just know that
makes sense
i would be theo and i would be theo and
on my podcast i would this past weekend
i talked nonstop congratulations you
know what the second the sucky part
about if i was jumping into your body
yeah cuz i'd be like [ __ ]
i can't even take advantage of [ __ ] a
lot of chicks
so it would be terrible yeah i'll be
like when i'm crystallized i gotta be
home with my wife and kid yeah
oh christopher after he settled down
like what
if i was you
all right and i will i got a show at the
wilton in los angeles we added a second
show over there and that's may 7
and that is saturday
and then also uh albuquerque new mexico
you did it daddy midland texas yeah
thanks man nice lubbock texas and dallas
texas that is may
uh 18th through the 21st and then
savannah georgia augusta uh montgomery
and columbus and that's june 2nd through
june 5th gotta watch johnny mercer
theater all right guys let's take a
little short break here before we get
back to the program chatting with these
crazies
let's talk about a little skincare can
we talk about a little skincare right
now if your skincare routine is
basically you washing your face in the
shower with that one shower gel that
you've been using since high school
maybe using the three and one all right
it's time to level up man you got to
take care of your skin because it turns
out that regular body wash you have been
using that three in one you thought was
good enough is probably damaging your
skin that's right man but thanks to
lumen you can drop that bottle of three
in one and start using products that
actually take care of your skin man with
lumen i get the highest quality products
all their products aim to help with
those stubborn acne scars under eyes
dark circles i look like a raccoon right
now whatever i haven't slept lately
wrinkles sun damage dry skin oily skin
and more lumens got you covered man it's
easy all you have to do is take a two
minute quiz on their website they'll
tell you exactly which routine is best
for you based on your skin care needs
all right guys i swear skincare
shouldn't be that complicated the thing
we dread doing and thanks to lumen it's
so simple it takes me less than 90
seconds out of my day all right i put it
all over my face man that's why i look
so young youngest in here that's for
sure level up your skin care game with
lumen skin today go to lumenskin.com
that's u m i n skin dot com slash cats
to get your free trial of lumens
products that's lumenskin.com
cats get your free trial of lumens
products lumenskin.com cats before we
get back to the program
i need to tell you about america's
number one meal kit we're talking about
hello fresh hello fresh you're getting
farm fresh seasonal produce easy to make
recipes delivered right to your door
every single week ingredients travel
from the farm to your freaking doorstep
from farm to door man that's how they do
it
at freaking hellofresh all right you
need quick easy recipes you don't have
time to sit down and do all this fancy
stuff it takes hours you got kids got
errands run you got a job you're tired
well we got you man hellofresh has 50
different weekly options you can skip
weeks when you need to change your
delivery date change your meal plan
whatever you want hellofresh app has it
all for you all right go to
hellofresh.com
king16 use the code king16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts all
right
it's hellofresh.com
king 16 use code king 16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts
america's number one meal kit hello
fresh now let's get back to the show bo
you guys let me just tell you right now
you're all oh god no he goes into this
other thing where it's like this was
going to be great
right now no it's not bro
he's the chocolate egg you're there
that's not i was just going to [ __ ]
say
that
that's his son
i was just going to say
you guys are all great guys i wouldn't
[ __ ] be in this room as many times
with you guys if i didn't love the [ __ ]
out of you dude i don't know
well you're all great guys you really
are okay man you're all ordinary
i need you to [ __ ] off your tone though
is like
like a like a basketball coach who's
down by four this is what credit
championship i need you to like can you
say it like like softly softer can you
like so aggressive you're so aggressive
i know i know okay you know how much i
[ __ ]
you know what would be great is if
during all of that they there was only a
shot of me zooming into my face
[Laughter]
just soft enough just seeing my little
i know it's
like a single like a tear is like trying
to force itself out try it again so
chris soften it up all right take two
all right
there you go i'm i'm not i don't want to
hey hey look at me i got you we're here
for you all right
all right
yes you want to hold my hand come here
hold my hand yeah there you go hell yeah
he's never held a black guy's hand
either
especially not that here i haven't
you're right yeah does this feel good
yes let it happen i've done it there you
go all right
all right if
if
you guys
weren't in my life
my life would be much worse
and i'm not
i don't know if i would be alive and
that's the truth
oh there it is
you guys were there for me during my
darkest [ __ ] and i love you all i love
the three of you man i love you there it
is
you know we don't we can't be scared of
that we can't be scared of being
touching we can't be scared of being
vulnerable it's important
we don't all have like i don't have a
big family you know what i mean i just
got my mom who has [ __ ] dementia yeah
i don't have a big family i love y'all
yeah hell yeah yeah i love you guys man
[ __ ] goddamn i can't believe we did
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
three times i'm already crying
[ __ ] barely on the show that guy's
question i haven't done all morning
this is the one time i'm not crying
yo what up brennan theo chris this is
andy from ontario canada coming at you
and i got a good one for you today i
know
winter's gone we're all trying to lose a
few pounds trying to get on that johnny
hips cry action yeah man i love it is
that a slug the best way to do it is by
running right or so they say so what are
you doing are you hitting that indoor
treadmill action
are you lacing up and running straight
outdoors let me know doors dude i'm
actually roars i'm rowing
with that now yeah get outdoors man i
got a rolling machine and i'm a bad
ain't nothing like motivation i think
that's great yeah outdoors is good man
because you get to feel the sun and it's
not even necessarily about getting like
the color it's about what is it about
feeling what just feeling with the earth
you know what i mean it's like my knees
bro you're not pushing me that much man
just say god man that's really part of
the right it is sort of the right would
it be crazy that god loves you though no
that would be awesome bro it would be
awesome and by the way how about you
remember that yeah yeah god dawg oh god
both of you guys are so you know what
i'm saying you remember that
[ __ ] yeah you're right out of
anybody in here yeah i just think
conversations we have
i think the most talented guy in the
room i joke around thank you brothers
i joke around about
no god and [ __ ] but i don't know dude i
like i know people say like no we know
you don't know no no you don't know but
you don't know but you know so i'm
envious of people that
actually double down on and believe it
but either way though it's something
when somebody says no wait there's no
god it's like how the [ __ ] do you know
dude well here's the fact there's no
idea here's a philosophy thing okay
let's say you don't believe in god right
but you live with the principles that
there is a god and you believe for the
reason is if there isn't you're making
the bet that you don't want to be a
person that lives terrible because you
think oh there's no god and then there
is gates
[Music]
you get to the pearly gates he's like
that's what they're going to do
you're going to come walking up like oh
[ __ ] there's a guy that needs to look at
the clipboard and be like hey
like it's the vip club yeah
sorry chris gang gang baby should have
got that hit or not yeah
that's it i mean it's like dancing this
isn't about like god or not this is
about how you live it's about what kind
of person you want to be and that's the
principles of that so it's like fighting
over like if there's something in the
sky that's not the point of it i mean
there is there is going to be there is
some sort of science in like that we're
connected like right now we're far apart
from each other like this but there's a
science of that like the atoms are
connecting us that's why sometimes you
think like hey i was thinking about you
and you call it's because we're probably
telepathically connected to that point
eric also in the in during the lockdown
during covid when we couldn't be around
people that's why suicide went through
the roof yeah yeah 100 you need to be
around people it's just it's in our dna
yeah
so i'm just saying that's what some
people would consider that's
spirituality that's what the thing is
and so human beings sometimes are we
we're just like we can't think beyond
stuff so we need symbols those symbols
mean something that's why religion's
there exactly that thing you named is
pascal's wager
pascal's wager that's what i'm talking
about um yeah this episode's called
going deep i just think that uh that's
why i'm here doing sprints outside is
this [ __ ] when it comes to working out
but i love walking no but i'm saying i
like i walk but on what i'm saying is to
get my like cardio in i like i like this
rowing machine because it's good for my
legs i'm 50. okay i can't just i can't
be out here like like i'm doing like you
know no but when you're out my size
thinking about how hard the run is and
stuff yeah wait a minute
i'm avoiding rattlesnakes yeah i spent
my peloton
all the time pelton all the time i was
like man maybe i should just get a
regular bike i mean since i was kidding
i got a regular bike i'm like this is
way more yeah
it's funny but i'm saying i'm not saying
one of the others it don't got to be one
or the other no no no you're right the
question is the guy's asking what do you
do so i get in shape what do you do we
know what you're all you're working out
all the time yeah i'm on hank's program
i've been on it for a [ __ ] month now
and i'm just feeling really great you
jacked yeah no i think that i think
burpees are really good um i do i think
jumping is good um you know depending on
how big y'all jumping is good this
sounds like a guy that's never worked
out no no jumping just jumping jacks
that's all you want dude but i mean
you ever jump in a box over and over
again it's hard as [ __ ] it also keeps
you active oh what do you know bro
except the fact that you just [ __ ] up
guys how do i [ __ ] up you dude i [ __ ]
up doing what i said jumping jumping
over there
jumping using burpees dude
he has a kid now his brain is like
simple
are you in um what's that place called
gym
oh no it's
tibet
you're jumping bro do you ever jump
around
jump rope
it's the hardest [ __ ]
i do [ __ ] chin ups jumping around and
push-ups
that's all workout will you oh yes it is
try it bro
do you ask me a question and then tell
me to shut up dude try jumping around
it's not because you're not saying
anything i am too i don't know
yeah try to do 100 jumps hey guys yeah i
love to hang out but i got to go jump
you're out of your mind that's all right
okay what do you got videotape he's
gonna put out what do you do jumping
with chris i do indoor outdoors
do jiu jitsu i do yoga for like a month
no he's been doing jiu jitsu i do yoga
day i've been doing a lot of stretching
too now i like that [ __ ]
i look like the pigeon [ __ ]
most animals don't stretch before they
hunt but yeah they stretch how do you
know before they hunt those attitudes
[ __ ] off for shopping yeah yeah
they're out there lions are out there
this is an eric boom boom boom [ __ ] get
y'all get your oh
get your [ __ ]
chocolate lion baby
stretch man they have to they go they
run fast
yeah
but yeah man i believe that uh chin ups
and jumps dude
you do that your whole body changes do
it your whole life
can you like can you like specify the
jumping no
puppy jumping on the box
box jump yeah i know but i was [ __ ]
saying it because i know he didn't know
what a [ __ ] box jump is like don't
die how dare you jump on i was 170
pounds ago i used to
jump up boom stand up back down boom
burpee bro
what say what you want a prisoner but
it's legit yeah but that's that prison
yeah but that's you ever seen prisoners
they're [ __ ] jacked not all of them
well no the guys that don't work out
because they're defending their own butt
dude
there you go
stretching
behind you
honestly i did jumps right after that
on what looking look this guy looks like
he jumped in front of a
van dude
looks like he jumped in some dick
hey guys where are you at there
that was me
after my jumps
me after my jumping
uh well you do have a big head that's
what you look like
look at the feet
those are the life rip socks go get
those at chrisley.com
what is happening
what else you got nick i look kind of
cool like that honestly make sure make
sure you check out riffing with griffin
but i think being indoor and outdoor at
the same time is good also like a what
like a tail what are you talking about
like a freaking
what a converter coming back to snapchat
were you working out in a convertible
what are you talking about indoors and
outdoors at the same time yeah you lift
weights indoors run outside you are a
crazy person sometimes man what yeah
what are you talking about indoors
outdoors me you're the one you got a
sunroof in your house go ahead and
deflect go ahead you're reflecting
you've still got problems jump guy
okay jump rope for heart over here with
the guy when people drive by he's
jumping up and down i see him feels the
guy in the boy band that just like
deflects and talks about everybody else
you know what i mean hey man get your
base up man
what's wrong with your trouble yeah yeah
yeah you got his eyeliner he's over here
singing like an asian yeah
come on man what's this guy one day
what's good it's your boy blake tunji
out here in the central east and i got a
question
today on reality bites back besides theo
and bird who do y'all think was the
funniest me personally i gotta go with
my boy darnell but we gotta know what
y'all think let us know
this guy is a obviously
a chef i bet it is his job he looks like
a chef
man is he saying road what does he say
reality bites what is that reality bites
back uh
and all that [ __ ] no this was a show
different show on comedy central oh
uh let's see chris fairbanks
tiffany
hold on tiffany haddish bert crisher
moment dale's a monster dunno rollins
amy schumer theo von woo
what he said besides theo kyle cease
about what how old is this like who
who's the best on there
oh the funniest he said yeah oh so take
theo out of it i mean nobody kills
harder than uh
donnell rocked moe mandel's a beast too
though
danielle killed oh this is old school
wow look at that if you're talking about
murder though donnell no doubt agree 100
chris fairbanks is so funny too
everybody on here is really funny i
haven't seen jeff garcia in a long time
me neither does he play anywhere but
ontario have a strong chin right there
theo he's always had that i was going to
say this in the beginning dude when you
get older you're going to be the guy who
talks like this
when
but when you get older you're going to
be like this and you're going to be like
right about right now
that's you dude but it looks like one of
those dragon masks that you can just
take off like this you know whatever
people are going to ask yourself
people are going to ask you where that
is and you're always going to say you
see that thing right there it's past
that
you're never going to point to the
actual toothpick you're never going to
point
where is it where's the thing you see
that thing right there all right so no
he's pass that
down here he's going to point with his
chin no he's like how would i get from
being this magical creature right here
the other imaginable creature you
talking about white face bubble gum yeah
no dude your shit's gonna go your face
is like this dude in about 10 years your
face is going to start inching this way
bro by the time you're 80 it's going to
you'll be out here you see that thing
hit there take a left right there yeah
you know what you guys are like opposite
you have zero chin and a lot of forehead
careful
[Laughter]
first of all i'm one eighth pontiac
that's probably where i get my chin a
car wow huh look at the like theo's
sitting in the thing i'm sitting in that
chair like you're a one
yeah
his posture is insane
and your shoes are laced to them one of
god's favorites dude that's who sits
like that maybe a young king god there's
some monsters on that [ __ ] show now
people love to get hit up all the time
like do you have access to the show i
never even heard about what was the show
it was like a competition show it was
like a fake reality show where everybody
was a contestant and then we did like
each each each episode was a
was like a rip-off of a real reality
show oh
that we that we shot were you as a
comedian back then yeah i've just been
doing comedy for like three years wow
wow what was it on
comedy central who is your best friend
you know why theo's sitting like that
because that's the first time he's had a
black man behind him so he's a little
bit like he's like
i've never experienced this before
who did he
look at me is he looking at me i wish i
was eric so i could say it
who did you get close with on that dude
you can think it though
uh what did i who did i get close with
on there moe mandel
uh
christopher fairbanks and amy schumer we
were all pretty close on there that's a
good group man
that's cool
i had no idea kyle cease is making bank
now he's like doing
oh he's was he in it he's like a
motivational speaker now right yeah
he doesn't do comedy more he just does
motivational speaking yeah actually he
went directly from that show right into
motivational speaking i remember he he
do you know he's making bank uh i the
just tickets for these are really
expensive oh wow there's like weekend
retreats and good friends
i don't know he turned into a cult
leader well i'll say this
yeah if you have blue eyes you can be
that you can sell anything you don't
have blue eyes you can't you're already
doing that job no i know the blue eye
can be cult leaders 29
yeah it's not so bad maybe that was a
weekend thing i said
he's a motivational speaker so because
he crushed so hard in comedy now he did
this he was always doing that though he
was always like he was always like going
to colle doing a bunch of college gigs
and talking to people like that yeah he
was so nice yeah yeah he was so nice
that seems dope i haven't seen him in
years yeah i've seen him in a long time
the absolutely everything passed and if
you don't know who that is watch 10
things i hate about you he's in it yeah
he's
oh well it's a good movie he's like what
was he googie boogie oh yeah
he was great in that and he's also the
slow clap guy in and the reason why i
know this because if i was hosting back
then and you want to bring him up
he would have like you have to say these
three things ah yeah got it
credits
gang baby love you bro thank you for the
question and i think that yeah i had no
idea theo did that well we're going to
say theo we never saw him no no he said
besides no he said besides steve i said
mo mandel all those people were funny so
it's like you know plus amy you can't go
wrong with anybody
some of them are not funny but yeah
was a monster back then it's honest
who you want to name them you want to
pick up some names
you don't want to go on over to my
patreon to find out
and what's the link or ours
um
sting in the wing what's up this is ben
coming to you from indianapolis out here
in the trailer park we're up early and
this is just crowder because when you're
poor it takes a little more time to make
money but sounds like i'm doing it
that's all good but uh so king it or
sting it my brother lives in my shed
i'll give you a little back story we'll
go check it out
so my brother got himself into a little
uh a little sticky situation where he
was uh rehomed is what we'll call it so
uh okay i decided to take him in as a
stray here a straight i had a uh
uh you know a little shed he could move
into
show the
blanket
and then inside here's what we've got
um so he's gonna get robbed yeah we got
the uh now we got the abode here is he a
dj he's got it all i mean everybody in
that trailer park is like oh y'all over
going you know
but uh yeah
that's it so uh king and her sting it
brother lives out here in the shed
love everything you guys do for real
dude really killing it man
and um
gang gang buzz buzz sword
well look i'll say this man i like the
[ __ ] i don't like where that stool is
kind of positioned that's the part where
i don't know you how you would use that
area that's where he makes his bombs
is this the unibomb yeah yeah i've been
trying to live in theaters for a long
time now the rest of the area i think
looks pretty usable but
i don't it looks like there's different
paint spillings and stuff in there that
doesn't look that safe to me
is that a co2 is that
that yellow can right there i know
that's a flammable gas
right there yeah yeah to the left right
there that is not
you know what i love about how theo's
talking about this it's like if we're
watching the redneck olympics yeah and
he's one of like the the commentators
he's like you know i'm not sure if
they're gonna be able to uh
that's flammable right there he's gonna
be docked a few points you wanna go
ahead and get that out of there i don't
know if you put the stool in that
position especially if you're living in
a stool if you're living in a wood shed
you do not want flammable objects in
there do you that is technically a car
seat not a bed so we're gonna dock him a
few points for that the rocky heart
picture show poster directly across from
the godzilla is a no-go
i'm trying to show you guys that i have
some you got to look out for the guy the
guy's already living in it
by the tennessee judge
so i'm not surprised that uh
let's see what alabama said yeah am i
flying alabama you know i'd like a green
light
purple is a no-go for me but that's
personal style
the purple little game yeah
dude i think sometimes i think you gotta
is that a wine
uh right oh he's making prism wine in
there what is all this [ __ ] in there he
i think bran
i think that by the way hilarious was it
a radio shack when he said king it or
sting it your brother lives
like
like what a way to try to kick your
brother out
this brother's watching it's like what
the [ __ ] do we a coward dude
you're [ __ ] just kick this dude out
man [ __ ] coward ass
[ __ ] it's hilarious dude i think you
gotta get you look man you gotta keep
your brother close as you can like you
can't
if he doesn't go here where does he go
yeah good point what statement what
state is this
his brother's gonna freeze to death heat
is not the issue
i think heat's the issue and that's why
he's in the because he's got too much
heat on him yeah he didn't want to
[ __ ] but i think i think that uh
what what i want to know is what are we
king or stinging are we kinging or
stinging him letting his brother sleep
in the shed or king and stinging his
brother in the shed his brother in the
shower okay
would you allow your brother to sleep in
a shower if you had one
i would allow it but i would tell him to
come inside the house but if he doesn't
have the room they don't have the room
he well he lives in a trailer park oh he
does okay okay choice was it did the
brother go i'm fine in the shed right
true yeah we don't know the whole thing
i'll be cool in the shed the brother
definitely did that look how you don't
decorate a shed that much if you don't
like it i've lived in a small place
outside of someone's house very close to
the house probably
11 or 12 feet from the house so you were
in a car uh-huh no it wasn't a car it
was a very small it wasn't a guest house
just another room it was a was it an
outhouse because it wasn't a [ __ ] but it
could someone could say it was a shed
and when was this this was probably this
is what i think when i was like 19 years
old and that's dude here's the alarming
parts of it one
you don't have any you're at the will of
mother nature as far as to if it's warm
or cold
so you don't have any you can't like do
something how you if it's warm or cold
and when it gets wet a lot rain comes in
under the door here's the other question
what about chicks
you don't know any chicks
we knew that yeah i mean you never know
it might be a handsome devil he's like
come back to my shed girl yeah if you
play the hey i'm just close to nature
vibe you could maybe get some yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't believe in this whole
government money
yeah you guys are right taking the
higher ground by [ __ ] the having the
wet ground yeah
yeah yeah
i hear i'm one of biden's buddies right
here
living out here in biden's aquarium dog
that's
yeah look the guys that seem like a
beautiful guy i think this is a great
group that they have i need to know how
old he is i wish his brother was there
so i'm stinging this because like he
should have walked in and his brother
was sitting on the stool making [ __ ] i
agree like he's doing this behind his
brother's back just to show like my
brother ain't [ __ ] he's like this and
he's living he's like this at the desk
he just goes like this
[Music]
leave me alone
his brother's making chris's merch in
there
[Laughter]
he goes like this
no no he's not no dude let me do the job
sorry i hear you nobody lets you tell a
joke it's impossible
anymore i'm sorry to do it again okay
okay no it's okay i'm sorry
are you doing the joke again nope it's
over
next so
sorry can i do my joke instead what's up
see you brandon chris
that other guy
got a kangaroo
fixing your own cars just a theo fan for
sure
this is being the right pin the house
here what do you see there's australia
you know you turn this your ground
look at the steel this
jesus christ is all fixed
to fix wow
the hambrick
beautiful
i'll say this god bless dublin he's not
saying
ireland
um this guy yeah i love it man somebody
stole my passenger seat when i was in
high school out of my vehicle so i've
been in this type of situation
and uh
i think you got to just take care of
yourself bubby i think
look out for yourself
and get the best stuff you can in there
oh you're passing your time is money
though that's probably taking that's
what i'm so long yeah it depends what
his life's like yeah but i think that i
think that that's uh it's ireland it's
cool if you're yeah true where you got
time so hold on back up though
then what happened he stole it who stole
the passage did you even know no we
don't know who sold it who knows and
actually it's a caller
please email the show and let us know
it's a cold case well let's reopen the
case let's reopen
find theo's passenger seat you know
where it is in that shed of that brother
yeah that's where it is i knew you were
bro
thanks for letting me have it yeah he
probably uses it as a uh
uh it was a 1984 ford escort too it was
great on the outside that wouldn't you
wouldn't know that by looking at the
seat but i'll see what i can do and get
back to you
yeah it was a good seat i had a tahoe it
was good and uh they stole the third row
of seating yeah and then the people
really yeah people say
it yeah what do you mean what do you
mean by that who you know you know what
i mean no just say it though criminal
ass [ __ ] okay
that's not the day i was looking for it
and then they uh and then apparently
that's like a huge thing like that third
row of seating and some of them
yeah the bench seating is like a big
it's a big thing for people to steal oh
yeah well a lot of people have church
vans and stuff like that people that
believe in god
those vans get the seating in there gets
worn out fast because people go over
them with their feet and everything a
lot of kids are back there people are
stealing catalytic converters now in l.a
yeah yeah
smoking at them a lot of kids probably
use them as big bongs bring up catalytic
converter chin okay
it seems boring so do you
what do you uh
what did you what did you have you ever
gotten your car hit or
broken into and stuff like that
besides the scene look up carburetors
real quick yeah
i mean it's on this screen that's my
computer but that's what it looks like
yeah i never knew what it was does it
say anybody smokes out of them i don't
think so they're stealing for money bro
people definitely get gassed up about
these [ __ ]
dude i had my car window broken i had my
[ __ ] mercedes [ __ ] taken like
recently just say just say what you're
thinking
who do you think did it chris oh i see
what you're saying um
actually i know what i know who did it
who well i know the race because i saw a
video of it what are they
they were mexican
oh how's that feel huh
i mean it was one of the options yeah
one out of two yeah
it's definitely
very good very good point yeah all right
hilarious
does everyone look like this yeah it's
not it's unreal oh do you do this on
purpose all the episodes
now nick's doing it on purpose
and these are great guys
looks like paul correct
what's up king the sting in the wing um
my name is bellman from central new york
nine games i had a king it or stinger
for you guys today oh yeah adult
oversized plush hoodies i'm not sure
what they're really called great one or
you know like a specific brand but
they're just huge plush soft hoodies
that go down to your knees
or shins um i'm currently wearing my
girlfriends because i don't give a [ __ ]
and it's super comfortable nice but yeah
king interesting
it's really it's an unemployment shirt
[Laughter]
you got no undies underneath now that's
now you think i'm white
wow really like by the way best part
about that is noises he's making with
his mouth go back that is unreal dude
that guy
[Laughter]
oh boy i will say this if you got them
beautiful legs like that man you know
what i like about this is you just pull
up the back like this and it's like
[ __ ] like that yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you ready to go like this this dude is a
real in prison this boy's a damn just a
damn christmas oyster right there
people will be up in that booty oyster
boy
oh my god my girl would love one of
these i would be get her one then dude
you're rich dude yeah actually like 40
bucks here kristen has one i just saw it
you guys act like i've been i don't want
to get it i just saw it
i know you've been mulling over this for
a few months now
bring spring spring 40 bucks get it for
your girlfriend who's the punching bag
when i'm not here i need to know are we
all doing it
here's the thing y'all will almost look
this if you get the one on the left you
all almost look the same i feel like
i uh my girl has one uh i got her one
yep for christmas i've never heard of
him uh uh one of these christmases yeah
you've never really heard of him what
what the [ __ ] you have one i've seen
people in them just because he's heard
of him doesn't mean he's had one and
your girl has one we have you've heard
of them no that's the first time really
yeah i've never heard of them oh wow oh
yeah so do guys been around without no
undies i mean mostly chicks are like i
want to wear it i want to have a latte
and a you know oh it's fall machine this
is
[Music]
hold on hold on
what are you talking about this is
insane it's like people are hiking the
insanity
when you're in get outdoors you creeped
you out
when you're at war in one of these
things like dude it just doesn't happen
are you hiking in
[Laughter]
apparently this guy don't have any
panties on
this one those
thoughts too right here on the left if
you out of your thought and this man
needs to get out of this and get a damn
job let's be honest bro all right if
you've got time to mill around he's
doing the gritty at the house and this
might be a sunday day you got to tighten
up what's inside of it is this a fur
coat it's just very very ghetto fur coat
no it's like synthetic or whatever it's
very very like soft soft gang that's it
eric would eat that to your ass well
that's the prize that's why it's got a
boat
huh you know
it goes like this how did you get into
that
setup i would go like this cool
oh wow
i like that a little bit i like that you
wouldn't do that
nobody in here
the butthole is right next to the button
i mean yeah and your nose is probably
right in there yeah you just
the nose is right next to the mouth yeah
it's right there i've had a little but
i'm not
i don't want pink guy man oh you oh you
don't want pink i do
you seem like it you seem like a dude
that would get pink eye
don't act like you haven't
[Laughter]
you guys have done it man what else you
got there are some scratch-off tickets
in some of those eggs
i forgot to actually get mine this year
so look like uh someone who would gamble
too yeah i got jelly beans oh wow calvin
loves jelly beans because i got him an
easter bunny that you put it in the body
and when you wind it up he shits out the
jelly beans that's so funny it just
poops back this is jelly beans too
and it doesn't shake oh
no they're all in the basket oh [ __ ]
guys not specific about it what i mean
can we still fire him
uh
no these are all
i love these dudes yeah here we go i
found it
[ __ ] oh these are yeah man you fooled us
my mom used to get us these at night
wow look how crazy nick looks right now
whatever no the problem is this
[ __ ] kept all the scratches yeah
yeah yeah yeah rick's got all he nick's
got all the scratchers in his wallet
nick's like i could have scratched them
all off honestly
i woke up this morning oh there's one oh
they're in with the jelly beans that
gray stuff under my fingernails
nick got drunk and just scratched them
all off
sorry i don't know if nick drinks or not
but he does look at how hey hey yeah not
on tuesday look at how dumb brendan
looks when he does it
dude check it out
no no no you're not dumb for doing it
just the bigness of you and the
littleness of that ticket he called it
dumb man yeah he did man well so what
dude i think you're doing good this
couple yeah but you look dumb bro
like that he's learning is it matching
it's not about how he i'm not saying he
is you know what you [ __ ] i'm
done with this episode
bye chris you made me cry and then you
smashed me all [ __ ] episodes i didn't
say anything we just want to make sure
you don't get to the pearly gates and
like you know
imagine if you're at the pearly gates
and theo walks by you like
see you bro
man
you know what i mean and then who's
gonna go where
yeah man it's pretty packed in there
it's not cool in there man don't worry
about it nothing i could do
i talked to the guy man instead of pack
right now doug
i stand in that [ __ ] you know what it's
[ __ ] fine it's
all the way downhill grab a shovel and
just work that [ __ ] bro and guess what
you dig up oh no here we go
a little jesus that's someone buried in
the yard
wow dark and i just got to hear i said
what is that noise in the way in the
background
eric's down there too kidding me derek
stella i'm getting in before theo in
heaven yeah so i'm saying that's why
it's so far away oh yeah
you know what you could be my plus one
thank you dude what i like taking him as
my plus i like how he just did you just
watch that
no she's going she's going anywhere i'm
dying before her you know
that's [ __ ] a hope if there is a god
yeah well it depends on how you look at
it
well all right that's it kids
moon towers april 24th 2nd through 23rd
arizona i'm coming in two weeks then uh
april 30th chrisley.com and i'm setting
these i don't know if they'll be on sale
or not yet but i'm gonna i'm gonna come
to atlanta georgia washington dc
i'm gonna do uh peoria these are just
some of them savannah georgia denver so
there's more so go to crusader.com and
check it out
i'm at the houston improv april 14th
through the 16th so check me out there
and check out riffin with griffin oh
yeah i love that my special drops april
28th on thick boy holla where were you
playing gonna be planning on bellco nice
um i got montgomery alabama and columbus
uh oh damn hold on
i got albuquerque albuquerque new mexico
midland texas lubbock texas dallas texas
and that's may 18th through the 21st
and then we got savannah georgia
uh
augusta georgia
and montgomery alabama and columbus
georgia and that's going to be june 2nd
through june uh 5th
we're going to get it done down there so
amen theovan.com says t-o-u-r gang
[Music]
wait a minute
[Music]
and the sting and the wings